before started working on this book I
wrote to-do lists the same way that most
people write to-do lists and it turns
out this is exactly the wrong way to
write a to-do list according to
psychologists and neurologists I would
sit down in the morning and I would just
jot down all the tasks I wanted to do
that day and I would put on a couple
things at the top of my page that were
like pretty easy to do because it
because it felt so good to cross those
off like early in the day and feel a
sense of accomplishment and I'd put my
big tasks at the bottom of the page
sometimes at the top of the page I would
even write things that I had already
done because it just made me so happy to
like sit at my desk and be able to cross
something off right away psychologists
call this using a to-do list for mood
repair rather than for productivity and
it turns out this is exactly the wrong
way to write a to-do list the right way
to write a to-do list the way that
genuinely productive people and
companies write to-do lists is that that
at the top of the page they write their
big ambition their stretch goal they
write something that seems almost
impossible to achieve because that
reminds you all day long what you
actually want to get done and then
underneath they write out a plan they
write a SMART goal they break that big
ambition into small components now that
gives me a way to start in the morning
but what's important is that when I get
something accomplished when I'm able to
cross something off my to-do list
I don't experience that sense of relief
that allows me to go spend half an hour
or 90 minutes like on Facebook right I
don't feel like I I can take a break and
I can go waste time wandering around I'm
ready to start on the next task because
at the top of my page I'm constantly
being reminded that although I'm making
incremental progress this is in service
to a bigger goal there's something
bigger and more meaningful that I want
to accomplish this day and as long as
I'm being reminded of that but I still
have a plan study after study shows I'm
much more likely to get more things done
and to focus on the right thing with
each day